since the middle of the 18th century
beginning in northern Europe and then
spreading to every corner of the world
people have become aware of living in an
age radically different from any other
in which they have called the modern age
or more succinctly modernity we are now
all inhabitants of modernity every last
hamlet and remote island has been
touched by the outlook and ideology of a
new era the story of our emergence into
the modern world can be traced in a
number of fields in politics religion
art technology fashion science all of
which have ultimately contributed to an
alteration in consciousness this is some
of what becoming modern has involved
perhaps the single greatest marker of
modernity has been a loss of faith the
loss of a belief in the intervention of
divine forces in earthly Affairs all
other ages before our own held that our
lives were at least half in the hands of
gods or spirits but we have put our
energies into understanding natural
events through reason there are no more
omens or revelations our futures will be
worked out in laboratories not temples
God has died and modernity has killed
him
pre-modern societies envisaged history
in cyclical terms there was no forward
dynamic to speak of one imagine that
things would always be as bad or as good
as they had ever been but to be modern
is to believe that we can continually
surpass what has come before national
wealth knowledge technology politics and
most broadly our capacity for
fulfillment seem capable of constant
increase time is not a wheel of futility
it is an arrow pointing towards a
perfectible future
we have replaced gods with equations
science will give us mastery over
ourselves over the puzzles of nature and
ultimately over death it is only a
matter of time before we work out how to
be immortal
to be modern is to throw off the claims
of history precedent and community we
will make our own identities rather than
being defined by families or tradition
we will choose who to marry
what job to pursue what gender to be
where to live and how to think we can be
free and at last fully ourselves
we are romantics that is we seek a
soulmate an exemplary friend who can at
the same time be an intrepid sexual
partner a reliable co-parent and a
kindly colleague we refuse to remain in
unhappy unions that no longer possess
the thrill of the early moments
we've had enough of the narrowness of
village life we don't want to go to bed
when the Sun sets or limit our
acquaintances to the characters we went
to school with we want to move along
with up to 85 percent of the populations
of modern nations to the brightly
illuminated city where we can mingle in
crowds observe faces or underground
trains
try out unfamiliar foods and sleep with
strangers
pree moderns lived in close proximity to
nature they knew how to recognize
shepherd's purse and make something
edible out of pineapple weed they
venerated nature as one might a deity
but modern people don't tremble before
the night sky or Fela needs to give
thanks to the Rising Sun we have freed
ourselves from the previous or at
natural phenomena the emblematic modern
location is a 24-hour supermarket
brightly lit and teeming with a produce
of the four continents proudly defying
the barriers of geography and of the
night we will eat pomegranates from
Arizona and dates from the Sahel
for most of history the maximum speed
was set by the constraints of our own
feet or at best the velocity of a horse
or sailing ship it might take three
weeks to [ __ ] from London to Edinburgh
four months to sail from Southampton to
Sydney now nowhere on earth is further
than 26 hours away from us the contents
of a national library can fit onto a
circuit the size of a fingernail and the
Voyager 1 probe hurtles at 17 kilometres
per second through interstellar space 20
1.2 billion kilometres from us
we are modern because we work not only
to earn money but to develop our
individuality to exercise our
distinctive talents and to find our true
selves we are on a quest for something
our ancestors would have thought
entirely paradoxical work we can love
much of the transformation of modernity
has been exciting thrilling even the
word modern still rightly suggests a
state of glamour desire and aspiration
but the advent of modernity has in many
ways also been a story of tragedy
we've bought our new freedom at a very
high price indeed we can pick up aspects
of the modern catastrophe in a range of
areas
it was the French late 19th century
sociologist Emile Durkheim who first
made the sobering discovery of an
essential difference between traditional
and modern societies in the former when
people lived in small communities when
the course of one's career was
understood to lie in the hands of the
gods and when there were few
expectations of individual fulfillment
at moments of failure the agony new
bounds reversal did not seem like a
verdict on one's value as a whole human
being one never expected perfection and
didn't respond with self-hatred when
problems occurred one simply fell to
one's knees and asked the gods but Emile
Durkheim knew that modern societies were
far crueler no longer could people who
had failed in them blame the gods for
their troubles it seemed as if there was
only one person responsible and
sometimes only one fitting response as
Durkheim showed in perhaps the largest
single indictment of modernity suicide
rates in advanced societies are up to
ten times as high as those in
traditional ones modern people are only
more in love with success
they are also far more likely to kill
themselves when they fail
but Derna tea has told us that we are
all equal and can achieve anything
boundless possibility seems to await
every one of us we too might start a
billion-dollar company become a famous
actor or run the country no longer is
opportunity and fairly restricted to
just a favored few it sounds charitable
but it is a fast route to an outbreak of
comparison and its associated pain envy
it would never have occurred to a goat
herder in seventeenth-century picker
d2nv louis xiv of france the king's
advantages were as unfair as they were
beyond emulation but such peace is no
longer possible in a world in which
everyone can achieve whatever they
deserve why do we not have more if
success is merited why do we remain
mediocre the psychological burden of a
so-called ordinary life has become
hugely harder even as its material
advantages have become ever more
available
modernity has in a practical sense
connected us to other people like never
before but it has also left us
emotionally bereft perhaps late at night
on our own in a corner of a diner like a
figure in an Edward Hopper painting the
belief that we deserve one special
person has rendered all our
relationships unnecessarily difficult
the first question we are asked in every
new social encounter is what do you do
and we know how much an impressive
answer will matter we fall asleep in
high-rise apartments and wonder if
anyone would notice if we died if it
were not already so difficult we're
asked on top of it all - smile
continually to hope against hope to have
a nice day to have a lot of fun to share
on holiday and to be exuberant that we
are alive modernity has stripped us of
our right to feel melancholy
unproductive surly in despair and
Confused not for nothing did Theodor
Adorno remark that modern America had
produced one overwhelming villain Walt
Disney though modernity may have made us
materially abundant it has imposed a
heavy emotional toll it has alienated us
bred envy increased shame separated us
from one another but wildered us and
left us restless and enraged fortunately
we don't need to suffer alone our
condition is at heart the work of an era
not just of our own minds by learning to
diagnose our condition we can come to
accept that we are not so much
individually demented as living in times
of unusually intense and socially
generated trouble we can accept that in
many ways modernity is a kind of disease
and that understanding it will be the
cure our book a replacement for religion
lays out how we might absorb the best
lessons of religion update them for our
times and incorporate them into our
daily lives